thank you
[Music]
everyone let's get the show underwater
dive one and dive two to send 25 000
feet we are exploring area 19 collecting
Rock samples and logging any new species
diving in T-minus 20 minutes all eyes
open for a straightforward sweeping scan
the usual yeah there's no usual down
there
systems up
what's with all these toys you're
hanging around your console lens
they're not toys they're figurines they
are definitely toys
thank you
ready for the drop guys
[Music]
so are you in style like Comic-Con guys
or what
uh
you're right yeah do you um dress up uh
yeah don't get them started unless you
want to see a million photographs
yes please stay focused guys
passing seventeen thousand Telemetry is
good
it's a beautiful day in the neighborhood
foreign
looking good team let's pull up the
bridge we're gonna map today
we're never going to look at something
different yeah there's like 100 more
sectors to explore Jonas can you confirm
O2 levels consumption is 11 over Mission
spec
IES
nervous more like you're a mouth
breather it totally is I can feel the
breeze from over here yeah
firstly it's called a deviated septum
second I just didn't remember deviating
it well saving your ungrateful
thousand twenty thousand feet
approaching the thermocline
checking out two lines in tank pressure
check the pressure on the auxiliary O2
tanks
that's not the problem
uh Jonas
man
you gotta be careful
I see that you're angry but I believe
that this is a reasonable and
responsible decision stop the time
full stop
so before you start yelling can I just
say
I did all kinds of stupid things when I
was 14.
look how I turned out
we're surfacing but I don't see what the
problem is this is your 26 trench die
without incident
Subs of electric predator
countermeasures and emergency dive suits
which you don't have
actually
I packed one more year doing the
pre-dive meeting you know
let's sit down
I don't know so be quiet women I can do
a seat belt by myself you know I know
you can do this
it's not your chords you make we've got
company
guys it's a MAG
that's not possible they can't go
through the thermocline it's not come
from the thermocline I'm tracking it
from the shore
flank speed
charging the Predator kind of measures
will be dead before they're online
double clients are only hope
moving hey cheese trucker
impossible well impossible just got
possible 500 meters to the thermocline
it is closing fast 100 meters she's
right above us
come on come on
dive one dive two switch the low
frequency light you don't want to
attract any more mix I've lost her she
can't follow us through
okay let's see going dark
I never crossed the thermocline at 60
knots
be careful you don't want to Brown the
engines don't worry I'm not going to
break the pretty toys
[Music]
yes
she's still on US 30 seconds for the
counter measures divisive she must have
followed our heat signature
[Music]
how did your pet shark get down here
Jimmy
is active
proximity alert makes
[Music]
the biggest thing I've ever seen
biggest smoke anyone's ever said
It's gotta be the apex predator
[Music]
incredible
solitary
it's like they're being called
I'm changing the diet plan
we have to see what they're up to and
what about me
well I thought we go
I wasn't asking you
oxygener all right maximum Predator
countermeasures are deployed right now
we are perfectly safe
right now yeah
see anything dangerous
back we're changing the mission profile
proceeding on heading 227 now they're
already off Mission they need to stay on
course Jonas you've gone way outside the
sector we've already met this is an
exploration Mission let's explore
copy that eyes open watch your Banks
really Matt so we're gonna follow some
giant sharks to our unknown sector
here's some dumb mark my words
one
commencing geographical scam
so beautiful
your mum loved this place more than
anything
I'm glad I finally get to see it
how did it used to it
you're grounded for the rest of your
life
I love you too
19400 meters ahead and holding
where are we going now into the unknown
that's what we came for
I've got high Tea's tracker ahead looks
like she's circling
[Music]
is some instinctual Gathering incredible
they're here to mate
that's why haiji has been acting
strangely right well Megs
scanners detecting an abnormal structure
no way
is that a wreck
what kind of seafloor station what could
they be doing down here
spectrums
no that's no wreck I'm getting heat
signatures off it